e
e e
committee here and take up the first
bill
173 you have copy of
173 I thought I had my bills all in nice
order here
but guess I
don't I just this
is
uh okay
all right I I don't need it anymore okay
there's no problem with 173
right I'm looking at the insurance
department this is an insurance
department request okay we're all we're
all good
okay all right
um so who would so um what we're gonna
one of the things we're going to do here
is not only take uh have subcommittee
but I'm going to need who's going to
make the motion so when we exact this
bill I know ahead of time who's going to
make
it so who would like to make the motion
of ought to pass on
173 carry
perfect
okay
correct and we all know how important it
is to get those blurbs done on
time yes you do that's why I said it was
perfect okay okay
um uh representative kry second by
representative burough mov ought to pass
on 173 is there any discussion on the
motion that ought to
pass okay all right
actually um we make sure who I have the
right the people for this yeah here
subcommittee so we
have okay and nether who am I subbing
for oh
yeah so we have MCU preli hunt Gibbs I'm
Gibbs hey we're both
short and I was going to say something
else about age but that's fine
oh watch it just watch it withdraw that
by the way it's representative Sphere
not representative par oh I don't just
for the
record oh go
on okay and then and Burrows and
rafter
okay all
right all right so representative car
second by representative Burrows
it's
representative spear spear oh my God I'm
sorry the record now I know what you're
talking
about and I always spell it wrong I B4 e
ex I B4 e except after
C
okay uh any discussion motion see none
all those in favor please raise your
hand one 2 3 4 5
six
okay H oh they changed this
okay
okay on to the next
one rela to insurance coverage for
pelvic floor
therapy okay so if I understand this one
correctly the um the department has
already generated a report to analysis
on this and that
um so that that's going to occur going
forward
and that at this point we really don't
need this commission or whatever this is
yes and uh and that what we really would
like to do is just um interim study this
bill so that in September you can give
us an update on on where you guys are we
already did the report and I already
provided it to you and the Senate health
committee so the work's done there's
nothing more to do we not identify
nothing we didn't identify anything okay
uh excuse me did we get a copy of the
report yes it got filed and I believe
emailed but I can provide another one
that's all
right we provide it
again fil means you sent it to me who
did you send it to
it went it was emailed to the whole
committee it was okay we got I believe
during the when the hearing was
happening it happened right then right
then during the hearing during the
hearing or immediately after so
okay all right so we even need need even
to hold on to this bill it's all it's
all said and done it's all
set
you no I'm want to kill
it I they're just telling us go ahead
and kill
it you
know I knowless you feel differently
about
that
okay
um look at representative
hunt seconded by representative
buroughs uh moves inexpedient to
legislate any discussion on the
question uh all those in favor please
raise your hand 2 three four five
six
okay
okay all
righty let me just make okay
so um that was one
okay on to the next one
uh relative to health insurance coverage
for patic for children under 19 years of
age who Okay representative Burrows
to a to pass second my representative
hunt any discussion on the
motion okay all those in favor raise
your
hand two three four five
six
beautiful okay uh relative to third
party liability in
Medicaid okay
um SP number
okay would like to make the uh make the
verb all right blur represent
mq second by representative
Burrows all right and ought to
pass any discussion on the
motion any none all those in favor
please raise your hand one two three
four five six
312 was representative
MCU second by representative
buroughs okay married
okay all right uh relative insurance
coverage for autism spectrum disorder
and down
syndrome um I I think this bill has got
some
issues um and I I think we should
interim study
it um can you describe any of the issues
yeah well the fact that we heard from
that one section needed to be that
they're repealing the wrong paragraph
not withstanding that we could fix that
but the part about how this new therapy
that's being uh used is actually a it's
not even accepted by Medicare anyways a
and who would you would think would
cover it you know no Medicare and
Medicaid both okay I guess young people
could be on Medicare they keep Medicare
is you know obviously fed Medicaid is
the state's got skin in it um but that
what in terms of this the application of
this therapy and how this therapy is
supposed to work okay it is it has not
really gone through the full you know uh
testing that you normally do in a
medical procedure what the process and
so in terms of um until we need to know
that that these practices are generally
accepted that I think it's premature to
to pass this
legislation you know how widely used it
is I I don't I don't mean in terms of no
I I don't know that it's how wiely used
it I anybody can tell us how widely used
this procedure these procedure what it
was
called that name for it but it was a
name yeah
right
right is anybody here to speak for this
bill or for that
issue
okay so that's what I'm just saying that
it it might it might come mean I I am
I'm going have to say being on this
committee and doing mandates all these
years the DSM is is I know is the Bible
and the DSM in terms of um it's gone as
far as finding it but they have not
there's no generally accepted procedures
and process and so I just think it's
premature for us to be passing this
legislation any other comments from
anybody okay uh representative
hunt second by representative
buroughs um
interim
study any discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
please raise your
hand one two three four five those
opposed
okay okay
yes I made a motion so it
was
353 okay all right next is 399 uh
relative insurance coverage for blood
testing associated with elevated lead
levels okay
so who would like to make the motion
Burrows second by
hunt any discussion on a to
pass okay all faor raise your hand 1 two
3 four five six
okay all right next is
556 prohibiting Health carrier firms
from establishing payment or
reimbursement provisions solely uh they
solely on the participating providers
lure so uh obviously this bill is rather
benign because there's so many other
factors in how they determine how the
compensation is but when I kept saying
to
myself
solely so you kind of laughed at me when
I said it so no
no now your your question was leg cuz
you're like where where did this come
from and what how does this got to do
with insurance and that was that was
really I was laughing because I had so
much history you know when when it comes
to the credit bureaus the credit bureau
on your for driver's auto insurance um
but this
week my uh my family practice which is
actually owned by the hospital uh called
me up and said um well your physician
who your was your primary has just left
uh he's going going across the street
and starting own private practice and uh
so uh you have this appointment for your
annual physical and um so we need to you
know have another person for you and I
said okay so who do you got and and
there was two nurse practitioners and uh
one of them had I had before so I uh I
knew knew
Bama without identifying the sex um and
then uh that the other one was also a
nurse practitioner and I said so you
don't have any MDS or dos or anything
and they go well no we
don't and so then I I was thinking about
this bill and I
says obviously it's just the solely is
just you know just solely but the two
problems I have one is a precedent that
if we did this how many other practices
are going to come in and say we are just
like them
you know and and we have to go through
this every time A and B is this a
disincentive for the hospital of the
family the medicine to actually go find
a doctor if they can get a nurse
practitioner rather than a doctor that
was my concern represent Burrows um to
the last point I would say that it's
just a reality particularly in um our
hospitals in the northern part of State
we we can't find doctors so when we
don't have doctors we rely on nurse
practitioners and you know and I
understand that you might want a um a
physician rather than a nurse
practitioner but they are qualified to
do a physical you know it's obviously
it's your choice if you don't choose to
do that but I think a lot of hospitals
and practices would struggle um if we
limited it to to doctors so I think they
should be compensated the same well I
think we're not we're not necessarily
limiting it we're basically
raising the compensation to the uh yeah
the family we're raising that
compensation and but in terms of would
shouldn't we be raising the composition
of doctors so that they well but that's
so so we can get more do so we can get a
doctor that's a different issue I think
right now this is this helps us and
helps hospitals and practices be fully
staffed to get people yeah right because
we're assuming that that there is there
no doctor who wants to work in New
Hampshire no but I can tell you all the
vacancies we have up at Memorial
Hospital that lie vacant for forever
because they can't find people right so
be choice between a nurse practitioner
and not seeing anybody I'm going to go
to the nurse practitioner right right no
you know if I have a heart attack or I'm
going to go to the emergency room or if
I have something serious that's another
story I hear you for a
physical they're perfectly qualified
right but but we are saying you know
that that we we we're not we're not
we're basically dissing doctors by
passing this bill because we're saying
the doctor's degree doesn't
matter it's not because it says you
you're not using it solely no I the
hospital still has the right or the
practice still has the right being equal
that's right if everything else is being
equal right so I hear you I just it's
just a little a little touchy but uh
other people have any feelings on this
subject representative prelli well I do
believe it it pull the mic close yeah I
do believe that it does open the door
for other Specialties to make the same
case so between optomologist and
optometrists or you could name you could
start naming all the different
professions I totally respect the hard
work of the arpn totally respect that
work but there is a difference in their
training and I think that needs to be
recognized it's a good example
optim I mean I'm not saying that they
equal but you could certainly start to
make the case you can make the case with
social workers and the you know we have
a mental health crisis so you can start
saying wait a minute we want everybody
to be paid the same rate and that is in
my opinion a disincentive for people to
go on to you know specialty or higher
education or um put in the time and the
work and the money required to get uh
addition different credentials but I I
totally respect the the hard work of
these uh professionals and how they
provide a service in areas that really
need that type of um type of
professional representative M let the
committee first it it didn't seem like
this bill does a whole lot to me it
seemed like the contracts would just be
negotiated somewhat differently and
potentially like if it if if a given
payer or institution negotiates on level
of lure now and we say well you can't do
it just because of the letters after
your name maybe they'll start setting a
minimum level of
experience
or you know number of patients
throughput or just some other means and
then we all have to step in and say well
you
can't pay solely based on how many years
you've been practicing or what's next so
not sure it'll have much effect I don't
have a strong position one way or the
other on it because of that because I'm
not sure it'll make much of a difference
my one concern is could it bring down
the level of physician salaries and
actually make that very obvious problem
of phys shortage worse and I don't know
the answer but what do you what do you
think I I I don't think that's the case
I mean the market is the market rate
doctors when they're looking for a job
they're not only looking at the hospital
they're looking at the state they know
what they know what the what they're
supposed to be paid based on what other
Physicians are are paid so I don't not
believe that and um you know for the
people who testified that 15% did did
make a difference so um and you know
again you can choose not to go to an NP
if you're not a nurse practitioner if
you're not comfortable with it I go to a
physic I mean I go to a physician in
Maine um just cuz she does a really
comprehensive exam but you know that's
again it's my choice
do you think we should include the other
mid levels
Pas I I no we don't want to expand this
anymore no I don't think we should
expand it yeah we don't yeah we're
talking about whether we want to do it
at all you nurse practitioners are
really well trained and you know they're
not going to do brain surgery they're
not going to you know remove your
appendix you know they're they're
trained to do certain things and they do
it as well as
doctors but why why not include PE I
mean there's plenty of orthosurgical and
cardiothoracic Pas plenty of them in
fact every cardiothoracic Suite in
orthosurgical Suite has a PA in it then
let's do another bill on that down the
road I mean I think we got to give them
parody if we're going to do it I that
would scares
me that again that now you're
reinforcing why I'm I'm a little worried
about passing this bill okay because
they're going to the Pas are going to
come in and say look you passed it for
them why proba that's not a reason not
to pass this I mean you know per worried
about worrying about the campell's nose
Under the Tent how often have I heard
that
expression okay representative rapor um
I mean as I understand it it's
reimbursement for services that The NPS
are providing that are essentially the
same services that a doctor is providing
so what the bill is saying is they
should be reimbursed at the same rate
and I think a point was made a minute
ago that NPS can't do all of the things
that doctors do or surgeons do it's just
the services that they provide that are
essentially equivalent to what a doctor
does and you know in the case of
underserved areas like the North country
and you know rural parts of the the
country it's really difficult uh there's
such a shortage of MDS and if nurse
practitioners are providing the same
quality of service and the same Services
it seems reasonable I don't think that
means and p s are compensated the same
in general as doctors just for the
services they're providing that are
equivalent representative pelli but this
is part of a uh contract negotiation
correct so I'm not sure why you know the
um providers can't work with their
representatives to have a better cont
this is a a individual contract correct
right so I'm not sure why actually this
is well this is a contract between to
whoever The Physician Office right and
the and the insurance company okay so
why aren't they having the conversation
to say this is what I want to do and I
think Anthem already recognizes that and
that's the reason why they're okay with
this this bill correct so I mean the
other insurance company should follow
suit without legislation well no they're
saying is that okay that the the request
for this legate obviously came in and
and they're saying okay here's what we
can live on and that and and when I
heard the list if I this correctly that
uh degrees are a level so that as much
as we all agree that MDS have more
degrees and have more experience than a
nurse practitioner uh I guess what this
might come into is that uh the nurse
practitioner has been around long enough
to make up for the difference where that
doctor had uh his his uh what do they
call it with three the The Residency so
would that be included is saying that
that's that's making it equal so in
other words what we're we're saying that
the only way that that nurse
practitioner is going to get the same as
a doctor is that that nurse
practitioner's been around a while right
but and it's highly
subjective I think well yeah it's it's
has all those subjective category that
that's where the solely comes in so I I
guess you just convinced me maybe that
this is okay and this is this is this is
harmless now because I guess it's true
there have a nurse practitioner has been
around a long time and and has all the
other credentials that an MD might have
they may better they well I think
there's another aspect you you were
talking about a doctor's office
negotiating with the insurance company
but a number of the nurse practitioners
practice
independently and uh they can't they
don't have anybody that would speak for
them to get the
solely uh you know the part of the
negotiation and so I think that they
ought to be able to if they have a
decent practice and they but it has to
be limited of course to doing the things
that they do that are the equivalent of
what the doctor does I mean certainly
not brain surgery or anything like that
and I don't think they would try to do
something like that right so I think it
it would be okay okay so how me are we
talking about just um primary care or
are we talking about other things the
nurse practitioners are technically
qualified for the way the bill is
currently drafted is just mentions lure
so it is not specific to aprns it would
be specific to any kind of lure we we
have that amendment to okay so if
there's an amendment that's just for
aprns then it be just aprns but we're
not talking about Services aprns have a
very broad scope of practice as long as
they're practicing within their scope
then that that's what their
reimbursement would be based off of and
I think it's it's
difficult to say because I think you
guys are all bringing up great points
there's a lot that goes into negotiation
everyone that has a contract with an
insurer whether it's part a practice
that has a contract or an individual
they're negotiating those rates and you
have a fee schedule so that fee schedule
I guess is what you're talking about
with services that that's what they've
agreed they'll be reimbursed for but
there's other methods of reimbursement
that are not necessarily A Fe schedule
so um I would just stay away from
thinking of this as Services because
it's the contract that this legislation
is talking about that they can't just
because they're an APRN have that 15%
lower and not all carriers do that
either anyways yes
okay okay um I mean I since we're we are
going to amend it to have the amendment
that is just nurse just the a uh nurse
practitioners um
I mean I guess the scheme of things that
it's
uh uh would sure be nice to get some
more positions in my family my my
practice but it's it's it's in this case
it's the negotiating is now is actually
the hospital who owns the practice and
then the hospital and then in the scheme
of all the things they're negotiating
with the insurance and now we're
negotiating the primary care phys but
yeah
represent
WS thank you Mr chairman since I'm not
on the insurance committee I just want
to understand it for when it gets to
executing it does this mean that
contractually uh the a NPS would get
paid the same as a doctor if all things
were being equal okay so in other words
when the cont tracks are are drawn up
and what they're how they value that
person is that they really do they're
specifically to that one person are they
really to a person when they when when
it comes to again I'm contracts are
negotiated differently so I think the
the thought behind this bill was to the
extent that there is an APRN practice
that is just aprns and there is no
doctor they cannot be
compensated less than if there was a
doctor in the practice but that's hard
to determine because again you're
looking at a number of different factors
so if this AP in practice if there was
other factors that would justify
compensating them less then that would
be the basis for adjusting the
compensation likewise if it's a rural
practice and there's no one else in the
neighborhood and they're the only shop
in town that would may be justification
for reimbursing them higher than doctors
it there's just a lot of different
factors and the way the contracts
Contracting it's done it can be with an
individual provider if there's still
practitioner it can be with a practice
it can be if it's a hospital owned
practice it could be part of a hospital
contract there's just a lot of lot of
different pieces to
this but in theory that's how it would
work it's everything is equal and
there's it it's just the only difference
is one's an APN and one's the doctor it
would require them to be compensated at
the same
level representative burrow I don't know
if you know this but I I mean I'm I'm
asking a question doctors in hospitals
because I live with one I mean it's very
clear what their what their parameters
are in terms of what they can and cannot
do particularly with Specialties and
doctors frequently get in trouble for
doing things that they're not authorized
to do so wouldn't it be the same for a
nurse practitioner they are given
parameters to things that they they are
they are um licensed to do and other
things they have to call on a
doctor they have a very broad scope of
practice so if a hospital were to put in
parameters about what an employee can do
that would be different but under law I
mean I'm not I'm notc but they have a
very broad scope of I think a hospital
can do that CU they determine you know
like U um we are in my hospital he's
gone so I can say we had a um who's a
bone guy what do they do orthopedic
orthoped
who did a um who did a heart procedure
and they canned him because what the
heck so you know hospitals do determine
what can and can't be done depending on
what your training is yeah so that would
be part in the scope of your employment
not necessarily a law saying you
couldn't do that or um an insurer I mean
it that gets more complex because if you
are hired and there's specific
parameters based on your employment
about what your scope is going to be
with in that set then the con then the
carrier can use that as a basis for
contract and say you know based on your
scope of employment you're going to do
and usually it's a list of services and
those are the types of services you're
going to build for and this is what
we're planning on reimbursing you for
and it's part of the negotiation but
there are so many different employment
settings and um different cave it's hard
to be General about should the bill be
tightened up to specify that it's for
comparable procedures that equal pay for
equal work well that's what is what
makes it too complicated to because you
know you may think a physical here is
the exact same as a physical up in Coos
but you know there's different practice
settings there's different LIC there's a
difference between MD and a do the do is
supposed to be doing more a longer so it
depends on those things you can't just
say every physical is the same and
that's why negotiate rates for
everything yeah I mean my my physician
in Maine for example um she spends like
over an hour with me ton of tests she's
probably a do no she's not she's an MD
she's an MD she chose to do this kind of
practice and um I don't want to use my
doctor's name but doctors uh in my
hospital do physicals that take they
literally have a clipboard and ask
questions and you're done 10 minutes
so they get paid the same as you know my
doctor would in main yes there's CPT
codes for the different procedures and
those would be the service codes but
depending on the type of setting you're
in the geographic area you're in all of
those things can justify different
compensation so I think trying to tie it
to specific Services as a whole level of
complexity that would be very difficult
for us to enforce from the insurance
department perspective are you kind of
where this Bill had started and we tried
to get them away from services and say
um this was kind of the compromised
language that everyone came up with is
basing it just you can't have a
different conversation based solely on
your licensure are you are you neutral
on the bill or yes we're neutral but
this is something that we could actually
try to enforce if we add in that level
of services there' just be no way for us
to to but what do you really feel about
the
bill okay uh representative Herbert you
have a question I'm just trying to um my
understanding of the testimony I heard
was basically it sold applied 85% of
whatever 100% is for the MD pretty
simple I mean if if for the r pins right
so does the does are you saying the
legislation doesn't actually do that so
that 85% is what is allowed under
Medicare and that's kind of where this
came up with but every rate is
negotiated differently every time you're
enter into a contract there's a whole
negotiation process so just because
you're allowed to go down that 80 to
that 85% doesn't mean it's actually
happening because there's a lot of other
factors that will go into contract
negotiations so it would be up to the
person negotiating the contract to you
know say why they should get more than
that and that's where the negotiation
happens with the carrier so would you
say I'm sorry I just on a clarification
just quickly so it's already solely not
based on
license there's a a huge array of
factors that go into contract
negotiation and lure level is one of the
factors that they determine yes so the
bill isn't as hard and fast as I thought
I was hearing so in other words if if if
you're a arpen and you have a
MD and uh um he's he's 100% whatever he
gets that's considered 100% the
legislation that I I interpret is that
this rpen that does similar uh work gets
85% of 100 now I don't know if if that's
going up or down but it but it says 85
and there's 100 so I don't understand
all the other variations that the bill
uh does
not discuss currently what Medicare
allows is that the 100% goes to phys but
under Medicare there is a set rate
schedule so every physician is going to
get what that rate schedule is based on
you know there's some parameters for um
inflation and Geographic areas but there
is a rate schedule and then the APRN
would get 85% of that rate schedule
that's a Medicare that's Medicare but if
there's in Commercial Insurance there is
no rate schedule so it comes down to
contractually negotiated rates and
that's for the carrier and the provider
to negotiate so under Medicare rules
they're allowed to base to use the um
APRN lure as one of the factors to
consider a negotiation and what this
would bill would do would say that that
cannot be the only basis for you varying
that reimbursement but there's still all
of the other factors that they can
consider in coming up with what they
feel is um appropriate reimbursement
rates okay I just that was my
understanding of the bill I thought it
was pretty cut and dried it's not quite
cut and dried that thank you but what is
cut and dried we're having a systemic
financial crisis in
hospitals
systemic and anything that I think
would
um cause costs to go down is probably uh
going to be required so I'm all all for
85 but but I'm not for uh all this you
sound like there's a lot of other
negotiations going on it's very
complicated contractual negotiations so
bankruptcy is not complicated once you
go bankrupt and a major provider in Mass
just went
bankrupt but that but this bill has
nothing to do with Medicaid Medicare
it's right is that correct so with this
bill going back full CL will this bill
what will this materially change there's
still a contract
negotiation this would make would make
sure that the credentialing Rises up in
the criteria but there's all this other
criteria that still could be used so it
doesn't necessarily mean automatically
that there will be pay
parity no so I'm not really quite sure
what this how how materially this is
going to change so if an insurance
company realizes in northern part of New
Hampshire I really need to find
additional providers I better pay them
they would have that flexibility with or
without this bill correct yes but could
this bill have unintended
consequences I mean I think you guys
have talked about some a lot of the
potential unintended consequences
financially speaking I think you know
where we have shortages in providers
carriers need to make sure they have
providers A aailable and that's probably
one of the largest driving factors right
now in contract negotiations down the
road maybe it might not be so the
insurance company would say I I need to
adjust my rates if I want to have a
thriving practice yes we have a running
debate whether Network adequacy which is
what that is whether how well insurance
carrier you know we've had problems in
the North country as a matter of fact I
think at one point I remember Harvard
was having a problem in the North
Country yeah I mean from the New
Hampshire insurance department
perspective we don't see that there is
going to be a huge impact on premiums
there may be one-offs here and there
where contracts may need to be adjusted
slightly but we don't anticipate that
being um a huge amount of contracts so
we will we estimated that it would be a
very minor if any fiscal impact but that
actually the the question about Medicare
Medicaid did do they distinguish between
a nurse practitioner and yes okay they
allow the distinction they allow the
and there's set rights there too you
don't think so
Susan so Medicaid oh so this say the
Medicaid is 100 so but just Medicare
Medicare is all right so I I guess I'm
at this point where where I'm at I I
think I'm okay with passing this bill on
the rationale that we need to do
everything we can to make sure that our
primary uh Physicians offices have
employees and have people and that this
is the purpose of this bill is for
nothing else is that we are addressing
the problem people have of that they are
not that they can't get a primary care
physician that there are so that that
they're they're seem to be so limited
out there and so the rationale in my
mind now is we're doing this so that
hopefully there we can get more and uh
for all the nurses I've talked to um
it's always amazing how many and I i'
ask him say why haven't you why haven't
you gone to that nurse practitioner and
and uh um they that this it's evidently
as much as we would think this is great
that you can be a nurse that can be a
doctor but that uh there not a lot of
them want to do it not a lot of them
want to get there so if we can
incentivize them to to go that way then
that would be good for our constituents
who need Primary Care positions what
about this amendment are we okay well I
just I'm just going to say I'm now okay
with the bill and uh and what I want to
do is have this amendment brought up and
this is the amendment that clarifies
that um this this bill uh is only for
nurse practitioners so when uh when I
get quiz when bills come in the future
and say uh me too I would say I can now
say to them well the reason we passed
this is because we were feel that we
wanted to do something to ensure that
there were enough primary care
physicians SL nurse practitioners out
there to satisfy the market that that's
in need yes re representative f rner um
I'm going to recuse myself from this
vote because my daughter is actually a
nurse
practitioner who doesn't awesome job by
the
way do I need to recuse my my
stepdaughter is about to be a nurse
practitioner I mean she's not one yet
though okay all right John it's Shing me
okay all
right he's not there yet right okay so
uh sure I have the right sheet in front
of me here
uh
okay all right
556 uh representative
hunt seconded uh by do you have to do
the amendment first yes spear yeah yeah
sure okay um uh to pass on the amendment
the amendment number
is8
17858 any discussion on the
amendment okay seeing none all those in
favor of the amendment please raise your
hand one two three four five6
okay uh now it's the motion is uh ought
to pass as am as
amended okay uh who would like to make
the
motion represent spear how many have you
done Burrows burrow two and spear has
done one who's doing this okay okay so
we'll let you do it and uh okay SE by
represent hunt any discussion on the
motion of ought to pass as
amended seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand two three four
five and no that was five and one
exstension okay five
all right insance cover treatment
protecting from
discrimination I have a comment on this
one okay so I I would like to inter room
study it but yes go ahead your
comment well one comment I have is the
act is uh incorrect it says IVF and it
should be IUI but that's another that's
a good Troy that's true that's but
that's another that's another issue for
another I struggled with this one
because of medical
necessity it's cheap enough based on the
fiscal note it's cheap enough but I
struggled with the medical
necessity and then
chairman you very nicely gave us a list
of all the mandates that you have put in
place and one of those mandates is
coverage for contraceptive drugs and
services not a medical
necessity
Medicade pays for vasectomies not a
medical
necessity so the definition of medical
necessity has been
interpreted a little Loosely in in cases
when we decide that that's what we're
going to
do getting past
that I have to say I'm for the
bill it's cheap and it does some
good better than
nothing my my comment on the bill I I
agree with uh with Carrie but I think we
can expect in the next couple of years
um additional bill s that will be much
more expensive along the same lines I
think uh in passing that which I think
we should just keep that in
mind representative Barz my question is
the bill talks about infertility but are
two women who want to have a child
necessarily
infertile is that the right word for it
well actually I I I took this thing out
and I was reading it really
carefully and actually it's not it says
regardless of
infertility in the bill it says
regardless of so then when I read it
again it said so that means
a heterosexual couple or actually it
could it means that a woman who wants to
get
pregnant who's who's fertile obviously
and she she doesn't want to have sex
okay a woman wants to have a baby down
have sex so so she's going to say is but
I I got my good friend here down the
street he's willing to be a donor so I
don't have to put in all that thousands
of dollars to get a donor but we're not
paying that bill doesn't include that
right yes this bill allows for this no
no it doesn't include the getting the
donor that doesn't include uh the donor
the whole as we heard was a whole huge
other expense right and so the reason
why this is only so cheap is that he
then provides whatever they need you
can't get it and put it in the
baster that's what this bill is is is
paying for this bill is allowing for a
uh other words in other words
so using your analogy now we're just
down to the $200 and and come on there's
when in the end of the day that if
people are choosing not you know that
they could they could do it but they're
choosing not to do it this is that's
where medical necessity is coming into
yes medical necessity of you know having
contraception okay was was that getting
control of the body and that was clearly
a uh I agree with you it pushed medical
necessity you know push the envelope on
it but that it was the issue was the
cost and how many you know cost and
you're going forward you know because in
terms of a lifetime you know contracep
and getting these you know the device
and so I agree with you with that
interpretation you know that was
probably a little bit of a stretch but
that it the political the politics of
the time was that uh we did not want
anybody to say that I couldn't get
contraceptive because I you know the
terms of the cost and that the the
monthly payments or whatever you know
would cost to to to have contraception
in this case what we're talking about is
uh that that this has nothing to do with
the personal
relationships of the people involved
okay so of the woman involved and and so
and I would say that that bothered me a
little bit that in the extra paragraph
of the bill they changed it from her to
them and I say oh my God are we really
going to get into that here in Commerce
do we really do we in Commerce want to
be into that discussion no no that part
no okay so that's when I started looking
back and I realized that it
says regardless of
infertility the whole bill is regardless
of infantility it's not even about
infantility at all I I I have to say
there's one thing that there's one
reason why and I didn't want to bring
this up but you're forcing
it what do we call it when a woman has
sex against her will and not because she
wants to what do we call that rape right
and that's what we're promoting by not
allowing this come on I'm sorry A woman
has the right to not want to do physical
sex she has that right and and she can
if she can go find a guy who's willing
to make a
donation for 200 bucks see she can get
pregnant no no you can't that's what you
look at the numbers that's what this
bill says no if you get done it on the
first time but you get up to six so it
could cost you $1,200 no if you don't
have the procedure the IUI procedure
itself your chances of getting pregnant
are very low they're already low to
begin with but they're very talk about a
fertile
woman even if she's fertile what's the
difference it don't you don't get you
don't usually get pregnant on your first
trial though some people
do oh lighten
[Laughter]
up I think we should I think I I just
this
I don't know I'm not I'm not ready for
passing this
Bill thank you thank you Chris what when
we had the that W woman couple in there
and there's all this money they had to
pay for the sperm why don't they just go
out and find somebody that they think is
intelligent athletic good-looking in as
sperm it was about the actual procedure
no I know but they could get that sperm
and take it and do the procedure
absolutely but it's just for the
procedure not the no I I understand that
but they I'm just saying that they could
have saved a ton of money by not having
to go to a sperm bank and buying that
sperm and then then use this
procedure I
yes represent representative
Cole I just look at this bill and
there's one part that nobody's talking
about and that's forcing an employer to
give up to 18 days off for that
section's got to come out of the bill
yeah so I have a problem with
that sry all right so we're going to
have to is this thing because we got to
fix it anyway that's
correct works for
me okay yeah and I think you have to get
into the current
century anybody like to make the motion
I'd like to have a woman make this
motion
well I I need
subcommittee you don't mind R you'll
make it for me thank
you
okay second might representative hunt
Okay uh and the motion is interim
study okay any more discussion on the
motion see all all all those in favor
say I
one two three four five six great thank
you uh uh
yeah I think a man should do I can I can
certainly write it for you all right
I'm okay why is this list long wrong
right okay but you understand the where
I was coming from in terms of my
okay
okay yeah
we
have we allow to do that no not allowed
to do
that I had you know when I was
scheduling this I was saying I wonder if
this might
happen um well I'm not sure I uh we have
all the Amendments ready yet we
don't
okay okay
right so we we have to wait we're have
we're waiting for amendments
anyways
and so
okay all right so uh subcommittee is
adjourned we'll reopen at
561 15
different
e
e e
we open up the sub committee
uh so first one is 561 relative to Prior
authorizations for health
care what did I do with
this OTP I know I'm just looking for it
on my cheat
sheet line
19 really
okay all right and there was no
Amendment
right no
Amendment what we did it need an
amendment okay
yes 561 I don't think so I don't know no
where's my department Jen is there an
amendment for
561 the prior
off
no Che
okay all
right I'll move out to
OTP okay just a second let me get get my
circles here
yeah no I'm all said I'm I'm now doing
the subcommittee Because no clerk
today
okay I see this now I see why I'm all
screwed up okay all right uh so
represent
MCU by represent buroughs
uh moves ought to
pass anybody have any problems with
passing this
bill okay all those in favor raise your
hand one two three four five
six okay did you make the motion uh
represent M you
did okay next up
okay all
right so who would like to explain this
amendment who's here in the department
anybody in the department want to
explain it or
uh I guess I I'm supposed to stck with
it all right
good yes
354 okay must be
Belgium
okay good
afternoon good afternoon for record I'm
Michelle heat I'm the director of Life
and Health at the New Hampshire
insurance department um I did not draft
this amendment but I can help you walk
through it thank you um this is for the
bill relating to the co-pay accumulators
or the so the coupons or discounts that
um pharmaceutical companies may give to
patients to help address their
out-of-pocket cost and whether those
discounts should be counted towards
their the patients total out-of-pocket
Max So based off of feed back from the
hearing this amendment was drafted to
narrow the scope of it and I believe
what this will do is allow the discounts
to go
towards the out-of-pocket Max
when those discounts are for drugs where
there is no other alternative treatment
option so it would not count in the
cases where there is a generic or
biosimilar or some other um m maybe
lower cost treatment okay so where's
that in this bill that is paragraph
two okay number
two Oh and before we get there this
would be amending RSA 41518 FF so this
is applicable only to group plans and
those are employer based plans right and
I see that on the back here is that
that's the r numer five high deductible
plan
yes there is um a carve out there for
high deductible health plans because the
way those plans work is you have to meet
the deductible before the benefits kick
in
right
okay so i' be believe high level that is
um okay the majority of what this does
represent you have a
question yeah I
there
are when we talked last time we talked
about tier
five now there are drugs still covered
by uh patents and exclusivity rights
that are below tier five and this looks
like it would be applicable to those
drugs that may not be anywh near as
expensive as the tier five drugs and we
talked about only limiting it to tier
five we also said that we were going
to it wouldn't be forever that is if
another drug came along then it would
have to move over to that kind of drug
or or you you know if there's once there
becomes a competition so there none of
that is in
there so it is if you look at um so if
we're looking at Roman numeral 2 two
which on the first page is lines 13
through 19
it a shall apply to any amounts paid for
blah blah
blah except in the case of a covered
prescription drug for which there's a
generic alternative biosimilar or other
covered alternative available but it
doesn't have the tier five
limitation yes well tiering can be
subjective that's typically what you
were describing is typically how tiering
is done but it's up to the plan to
decide how many tiers and what drugs get
into those tiers so it can very it's not
that all plans will have a fifth tier or
um that there's certain criteria for
what gets on that fifth tier so it's not
linked to that because every formulary
is going to be slightly different so
we're just giving
this car blch pretty much all over the
place no well not if there's other
treatments available this it has to be
one of a kind it has to be a medication
that is one of a kind where I'm having a
problem yeah you take something that
there are drugs that that are much less
expensive than what I typically think of
tier five and what we heard at the
hearing drugs for $300,000 a year those
kind of things that are less expensive
but been have been able to hold on
to exclusivity for a while through all
kinds of
mechanisms not some of them necessarily
all that to be comfortable with and I
I'm very uncomfortable with
allowing the kind of uh payments that
would happen that would exclude other
people who are using generics and using
biosimilar from getting the same benefit
okay so I and this has been part of my
confusion too because of the other Bill
555 okay which is that they're giving
those incentives because there is
something another potential alternative
that someone may be interested in what
what we're trying to do in this
amendment is only
address those particular drugs
that you could say coincidentally a
really high really high price could
coincidentally many considered a your
five but the end of the day they are so
expensive that is is um and and for and
and what the best we could do to try to
identify that group and what we're
trying to focus in on the best we can do
is is that that there is no alternative
there is no generic there is no
biosimilar that we're just assuming that
your whatever that drug is and that we
heard about the
hemophiliacs and the cystic cybrosys
okay that those drug that there's only
one drug but they are not the only types
of drugs for which drug companies have
been able to establish exclusivity and
that's where I have the problem
exclusivity alone is not what we want to
cover I hear you but I telling you that
exclusivity is not the issue that we're
trying to focus in on that's we're
exclusivity issue which was somewhat
related to the other bill in this bill
we're trying to address that people have
that these drug
companies know
that they have a very unique drug it's a
very specialized drug and they're
charging an arm and a leg for it they
can get away with it because it's
special I understand that and so what
we're saying is for those people who are
page two in a high deductible
plan because not because they chose it
if they were in they were in you know
getting their own health insurance but
because their employer chose it for them
okay that we're going to say to them
that yes that this independent charity
patient assistance program that these
pharmaceutical companies have created
that you can get the take that money and
not worry about any tax complication or
anybody you know getting a freebie or
whatever that you it's okay to accept
get that money and use has to be through
an independent charity patient
assistance program exactly so this what
if you want to talk what is the biggest
governor in this bill that that's the
governor is is that the the charity is
willing to give it because of this
truck they're not just giving they don't
give this charity assistance to anybody
and everybody right okay okay they're
only giving it to people who a have an
income they meet the income requirements
but B but more importantly is that it
the drug is has an incredible High all
right how do we find the copy of the 70r
70623 and and the
3112 oh wait a minute I think I have a
copy of
that okay I have a copy of everything
okay you work on that do there anybody
else have any other
question just to clarify the high
deductible health plans are exempt from
this because of IRS regulation IRS
regulation right right that was the that
was the Irish thing okay great thank you
did you want to say something
Ry you want to make a suggestion all
right you have to come over to the
microphone so we all can hear
it thank you Mr chairman Mike Rolo
American Cancer Society cancer Action
Network you have to talk close to the
mic thank you Mr chairman for the record
mic Rolo American Cancer Society cancer
Action Network and we uh thank you for
the opportunity and we uh thank you for
the amendment and we would be in support
of the amendment um just wanted to make
one suggestion that might make it a
little um clearer in paragraph 2 line
18 um where it says covered prescription
drug for which there is a generic
alternative biosimilar and another
covered alternative
available perhaps it might be a little
clearer if it said covered prescription
drug for which there is a lower cost
generic alternative bio similar or other
covered alternative
available so you're adding lower cost
I don't think so yeah no we I I that's
honorable to to put it in help clarify
it but it's in this case we don't want
anybody to think this in this case there
there is you don't want a lower cost
alternative the lower cost it it
wouldn't kick in in other words if there
was a lower cost they probably wouldn't
be doing the charitable contribution no
okay okay I thought it would make it
clearer for you I thought it would be
clearing up what representative spear
was trying to address but right if you
don't think it would then I will
withdraw my suggestion it's it's an
interesting suggestion but I'm not sure
but if it doesn't address it that way
then I'm I'm just trying to help but if
it doesn't work that way then I will
withdraw the suggestion and again we
would support the amendment and say
thank you for for uh for bringing it
Forward there we go
okay
uh amendment number that was
fun03
H all right uh representative hunt
second by representative buros moves off
to pass on the
amendment any discussion on the motion
seeing none all those in favor please
raise your hand two three four
five I just said is there any more
discussion
okay I just the the only question I have
is the insurance is the insurance office
okay with this can they live with this
or we just had a representative from the
insurance department yes they're okay
with it and I have been assured by the
insurance
companies that they are they think this
is a very worthy okay then fine with
it okay vote six to
zip make okay yeah I'll make
it you want to Bing the bill for you
want me to bring it for you can bring It
Forward okay okay representative hunts
second can by representative Burrows
uh on to pass as amended is there any
discussion on the
motion okay the motion clear all those
in favor please raise your hand one two
three four five
six motion
carries
okay okay
it okay next up is uh cill
555 pharmaceutical
rebates
okay um
I'll just move things forward here
uh
representative
okay all right representative hunts
second by representative
Burrows and the motion is ought to pass
on
amendment number
okay this
is this is kind of Bill I
like it repeals
something okay so as it turned out uh in
as
I trudge through
55 um 555 is that it it uh it it did
pass and I've been meaning to look up
how I voted but I'm pretty sure I voted
against it way back when but uh I need
have my Kristen look me up and see what
I did on this but um at any rate uh in
the wisdom of Senator Bradley way back
when he sunsetted the
legislation um and so you would think
that would be the rest of the story
except uh obviously when it came time to
uh what decide what we're going to do
with it that um they decided to renew it
and then of course the bill had a bunch
of other things in there about how they
were going to renew
it um and which was obviously
controversial because it was mandating
that all companies had to participate
even though some of the insurance
companies were not doing it so at the
end of the day um what we in terms of
looking at the St stat and looking at
what it does in terms of how it handles
these things in fact that the in fact
that the the marketplace is actually
freewheeling in terms of how they do it
some do it some don't some you know
whatever they want to do in terms of
conditions they want to do it um this is
not a place where we need to to
legislate that uh let let them do what
they want to do however uh in that
legislation uh that we have just would
delete by this amend
there is some interesting uh information
gathering parts to it and U I have
gotten an agreement with the insurance
department that they will uh put out a
bulletin I'm not sure do everybody know
what a bulletin is I we've gone across
that bridge yeah we did we did a
bulletin last year right okay okay so a
bulletin is the department is sending
out a notice to all its lenses in this
case the insurance companies and telling
them uh in implementation of a certain
law or implementation of a certain
policy um here are the things
expectations that they
have and so it's it's very clean uh in
the sense that it's you know the
department is members um and it doesn't
require statutory you know creation um
and and there's and they have a comment
period and people can respond and
there's plenty of opportunity for the
lenses to to work with it um but but in
the end of the day it gets us where we
want to be without having to pass
legislation see this
in it's not a rule no it's it's it's
it's out sort of outside of rule rule
making um so uh and having having uh
agreed to picking up that language uh
that the department said that uh they
agree with this
solution which as you might uh remember
they were not too crazy about the
original bill so uh I think we have a
wonderful solution to this
problem anybody in the audience feel
differently speak now or forever more
hold your
piece
okay so uh the motion hunt second my
Burrows to pass on the amendment any
discussion any discussion
seeing none all those in favor raise
your hand one two
three one two four five
six okay motion
carries of
hunt repres
Burrows ought to pass on as
amended any discussion on the bill as
amended seeing none all those in favor
raise your hand 1 two three four five
six motion
carries
okay uh last but not least right
557 and
this was a straight out to
pass
yeah did you want to do this Tim did you
want
to okay represent meu second by
represent
burrow yeah I forgot that you wanted to
do some of this other one I know any of
these other ones that you want to yeah
when we get to exact that's fine okay
all right we'll take that up okay uh
ought to pass any discussion on the
motion about to
pass see none uh all those in favor say
I one two three four five
six and we're
done all
right we're done
you
e
e e